the ways of the world often baffle
me I sometimes wonder if I miss the memo
about the most basic things what are you
supposed to make for dinner what do you
talk about in an
elevator why do people cut in
line how do you leave a dinner party
without being rude or do you leave it
all
my tendency to see the world like I'm
from outer space was a bit of a
liability when I was a kid true
story but it's been helpful in my
career I'm a
cartoonist when I first started making
cartoons for the New Yorker about a
decade ago I kept my ideas light and
quirky and please shout out if you don't
get any of them I'll I'll
explain I didn't draw anything too
personal I
mean personal for
someone I figured I was too specific too
hard to relate to and read possibly too
female it took a
breakup
[Applause]
it took a breakup to get me to start
drying more
autobiographically the pain I was
feeling although objectively pretty
run-of the-mill was impossible to
ignore I knew that drawing was my
strongest problemsolving
tool so I decided to diagram what I was
going
through
by making these drawings I could see how
my ex and I had hurt each
other and move
on on to other
breakups drawing from my own life was a
revelation to me not only because it
helped me understand myself better but
because it made me see for the first
time that people could relate to
me
now that I had this amazing tool there
were so many problems I wanted to solve
with
it the problem of
scheduling the problem of too many
things happening all at the same
time the problem relatedly of
time and finally dating
again there's an endless amount to say
about
dating there are of course problems that
can't be summed up in a single
drawing for these problems you need many
drawings one more complex problem I have
is with
God I'm Jewish so I'm talking about the
God of the Old
Testament my problem with God isn't
actually a big problem it's just I don't
know it it stayed with me my problem
with God is that he's too
[Applause]
confident for me creation is an act of
solving problems of figuring things
out God already seems to have everything
figured out he strikes me as more of a
king than a Creator and I'm not sure you
can be
both as an experiment I decided to
remake the Book of Genesis as a graphic
novel my version of God is not confident
and maybe not
coincidentally she's a
woman it's surprised me how few changes
I needed to make to the original text
which is sparse and ancient and lends
itself well to
interpretation for example the Bible
opens in this mysterious Moody way with
God floating aimlessly on the face of a
dark mysterious
void in my version I have her floating
this way because she's feeling
despondent about her limitations as an
artist she's made this messy wet mixed
up dark first drafts of the world and
she just doesn't know where to go from
here my version of God doesn't know
exactly what she's doing but she draws a
horizon line and things start to fall
into
place she banishes Adam and Eve from the
Garden of Eden not because they
disobeyed her but because by eating the
apple and becoming wise she feels
they've outgrown the world she created
for them and she needs to let them
go she scatters the Builders of the
Tower of Babel not because she's
threatened by their power but because
like any introvert she needs her
privacy when she destroys the world in
the story of Noah it's not because she's
incensed with
mankind but because she's incensed with
herself she knows she could have done a
better job when she made
us my adaptation of the Book of Genesis
is a creation Story full of false starts
and
absurdities but it's a creation story
all the
same one in which a self-conscious woman
even though she worries and makes
mistakes is nonetheless a successful
committed
artist when I finished my book I did
feel a new connection to the god of the
Torah and a new sense of belonging to my
religion I also felt a new sense of
belonging
period it's lonely being someone who has
no idea how to act normal but it's
profoundly less lonely being that person
in a world created for her by an equally
awkward self-conscious
God these days when I worry that I won't
know what to make for dinner I remind
myself that God wouldn't know
either this picture is giving me
anxiety it's like literally it I drew it
from Life
um this gives me the confidence to
embrace my cluelessness and just wing it
thank you thank you so
much